here's a story from the postimonial doj
announces multiple indictments against
whistleblower who alleged Biden received
payments from CCP Affiliated individuals
I I just I love this story because it's
kind of obvious it's just so on the nose
like hey I'm a guy who says that there's
corruption happening with Joe Biden and
then Joe Biden's like you're under
arrest it's just really that simple the
doj has announced multiple indictments
against Dr Gallup Luft the
israeli-american uh co-ed of a Maryland
Think Tank who gained notoriety as the
missing witness in the investigation
into Joe Biden's corruption the New York
Post recently shared a video of Luft
wherein he broke down the allegations
made against Biden and claimed that he'd
been arrested to prevent him from
testifying to the house oversight
committee with damning evidence against
the first family now long after coming
out as a whistleblower Luft himself has
been charged by the Biden doj for
allegedly engaging in multiple series
schemes involving the Chinese and
Iranians alongside a former higher
ranking US government official the
charges include numerous offenses
related to failing to register under the
foreign agents registration act arms
trafficking Iranian sanctions violations
and making false statements to federal
agents
wouldn't under Biden have to do the same
thing with pharah as well but uh I don't
know if there's more to this story or
what's going on I don't know if you have
a bigger view of this Natalie sure well
there is nothing more hypocritical than
coming after him for not registering
with the foreign agent registration act
as someone who has read pharah too many
times I joke I'm probably the only
American who frequents that website uh
Hunter Biden's name is never on there
even though it should be not just for
China but also for Ukraine also for Iraq
also for Russia you name it the list
goes on but it's important to remember
that this is just one of several
whistleblowers if you remember James
Comer who's leading these investigations
for the house he said that there are
about 10 whistleblowers seven of them
they don't know what happened to them
they just couldn't find them two of them
had been indicted and the other if you
remember he was giving an interview I
think it was on Fox he's like we think
they may be dead
um so keep in mind that even though the
story is absolutely ridiculous it's all
the ridiculous more 10 times over
because there are so many people like
him have you guys seen that crazy video
of the woman on the plane is like scream
aiming about how the dude's not real or
something I don't know what that was all
about I read something where she said
like apparently people were like she
claims the guy winked sideways or
something like that I have no idea but I
was watching that and after just seeing
all of these different conspiracy
theories at this point I'm like ready to
believe her that like a lizard person
was on the Block I'm kidding by the way
but what I mean I bring it up because
you hear the story and it's like well
some of the whistleblowers may be dead
we don't know where these ones are this
guy's being criminally charged after
calling out the bidens and you know
accusing them of corruption and I'm just
like yeah it's probably true like the
bidens are doing this and they're
panicking and frantically trying to
cover things up because what's what's
this simple solution here that all of
these whistleblowers Witnesses every
story every video every claim every text
message it's all part of some Russian
plot to describe the bidens Sorry
probably not the case it's so bold and
it's so in your face and I think it sort
of proves in some ways the guilt of the
Biden family what I mean by that is that
the same family that is so willing to
issue indictments against people who are
obviously calling the whistle calling
them out for their actions with hard
cold facts real evidence of course they
would be bold and Brash enough to take
money from the Chinese Communist Party
while Joe Biden is in office and think
they could get away with it I think it
just shows you the mindset of this
family and frankly how offensive it is
to the American people that they think
that they can get away with doing it and
that people like us are dumb enough to
just oh he's crazy to be fair though
like imagine what it must be like to be
in the Biden family and you're getting
all this negative attention and they're
going like the clintons did it yeah why
are you mad at us like you know they are
just following an American tradition yes
how can you take away our culture from
us this is our righteous relief I don't
understand yeah the Clinton Global
initiative and the Clinton Foundation
all that good stuff yeah I think that
the bidens we're looking at that level
of influence pedaling and Joe being
fairly incompetent I mean to be fair
like fairly competent he's made it
pretty far he was a senator for a long
time he's in politics for 50 years so
he's not completely bad at what he does
but uh he's not he's not on the Clinton
level you know Hillary Clinton she's a
special kind of witch you know what I
mean like she she was able to pull it
off congratulations to her and all of
the awful things she did but she got
away with it
chucked her hard drives into the Potomac
Hunter Biden brought it to a repair shop
in in Delaware and I think that sort of
was the fuse that Lit a lot of this off
because the American I think that's
maybe two some where some of the
frustration comes from with the lack of
accountability and investigations and
and really indictments at least from
House Republicans going after people who
are involved in the whole hunter-biting
crime ring is because the American
people are sort of getting this like
sense of deja vu because through this
hard drive through investigative
journalism and actual media reports
they've known about all this like gal
left is the name who's been around for a
really long time he's on the hard drive
these are stories that are sort of just
resurfacing and I think that's why it's
all the more curious why they're
indicting them now because gal left all
these types were saying these things and
have been for a very long time right the
hard drive has been out there for a
while we've written stories war room has
talked a lot about people like Gall left
all the other whistleblers the names
that are on the hard drive so I think
it's curious it's like why now I think
that same logic applies to why are they
going after Hunter Biden on taxes now
like what's the time well I gotta ask
for clarification you said she threw her
hard drives into the Potomac considering
how crazy the story has been was that
was that literal or are you just I mean
figuratively who I I guess a
metaphorical bear but my point is
because she smashed she had them smashed
with hammer the phone smashed the
Hammers I guess it's too euphemistic to
say they heard of the I'm sure I oh
they're gonna come up like fact check
I'm sure that at least one technological
device that belongs to the collection
family has been thrown at some capacity
into the Potomac I I will go on the
record with that I think it's a fair
assumption what we do literally know is
that uh the hard drives were purged with
bleach bit Yeah and aids for the Clinton
uh uh for the clintons smashed phones
with hammers to try and get rid of it
doesn't do anything by the way it's like
the stupidest attempt at getting rid of
data but uh yeah I mean that's exactly
what they what what they did so I wonder
if the bigger issue with the bidens that
they're just sloppy and experienced and
incompetent when it comes to being
corrupt and I think there is a lack of
discipline there crack we'll make that
we'll do that yeah you think that's it
yeah uh lack of familial leadership and
crack cocaine really just ruined your
ability to be a completely corrupt
family I mean we we know in early June
Anna Paulina Luna tweeted about this FBI
the FBI is afraid The Whistleblower will
will die if he is unmasked which seemed
crazy and also we all laughed because it
was like are you saying you guys would
attack this person like it didn't make
any sense but at the same time it's
exactly what this the simplest
explanation is probably what it is that
there is some kind of uh internal
pressure from the Biden Administration
to silence anyone who is going to oppose
them or challenge anything they have I
mean the Biden family lies to your face
constantly how many grandchildrens does
Joe Biden have because he just pretends
yeah well we don't talk about that one
not a lot to use the last name therefore
not real I mean this yeah his the hunter
Biden's daughter kid or something yeah
sorry kid was it a prostitute it's a
prostitute he then tried to like lie
about like he had her he hired her to
her found his foundation and he denied
it there was a paternity test they just
settled their their child support case
and one of the stipulations that he had
was this child cannot use my name I
don't I will pay a certain amount of
money for it but I will not acknowledge
it either way that's like old monarchy
tactics
so that's how the Biden family views
themselves that you were supposed to
accept that even when it's completely
confirmed that something is wrong you're
supposed to ignore it because they asked
you to
seems crazy to me with the guy that they
were afraid the Widow whistleblower they
thought was going to die was that this
guy
they were like we've got to hide his
identity because we're afraid he's going
to get killed did it is that I think
they clarified no and that was just one
of the ten they said they were worried
if the identity of the Whistler got out
they would die sometimes the cohesion on
the messaging from our dear house
Republican friend
same level sometimes there's confusion
about who they're talking about but that
had to do when they were unearthing new
evidence about a whole pay for play
scheme that had to do with Romania it
wasn't explicitly linked to that pay for
play because there's a lot of
pay-per-play there's a lot of countries
there's a lot of people involved but
also think too to your point why we've
seen so many whistleblowers especially
on on this front and this again is me
speculating but you know the whole
Clinton operation I think was very
seamless and well run in the sense that
the people who were in it
it was a tight ship with the Biden
regime what what they were doing it
seems like a lot of these people it
wasn't so much ideological they were
just in it for the money and you can see
that on the hard drive you can see that
in the emails it was just we have a
chance to exploit the vice president's
son and I think that's why you've seen a
lot of these people sort of turn on the
Biden family now those that haven't been
dissuaded by stories like this and I
think that might be why they're actually
trying to come out so forcefully because
they know deep down the people like Eric
schwer and the Devon archers of the
world basically all of Hunter Biden's
you know Yale call or classmates and
peers and roommates they were just on
The Money Team right it wasn't like oh
we want to spread democracy abroad you
know we want to do whatever the uniparty
wants to do and all these no they just
wanted to turn a profit and those people
I think are very easily turned with the
threat of oh well you're gonna spend the
rest of your life in jail if you don't
tell us so that's why if you do read
through the headlines like a lot of
these people behind the scenes have been
complying with either off the Record or
on the record interviews with Congress
but
it's sort of a painful process I think
time wise to let that that work let it
work itself my view of the Biden family
is like it's like Arrested Development
yeah for real you know like bite into
town with Hunter and he was and he's
just like what did you do and he's like
Dad I was smoking crack I don't remember
this is so much the internet because the
clintons didn't know the internet the
internet didn't exist back then really
now it's all just people are finding it
people are finding out what's happening
if this has gone on just because he
recorded himself yeah hunter in
particular saying I'm in business with
the effing spy chief of China but to
your point you know the axio story that
they had come out today where they're
like Joe Biden is Mr stronger I
would love again I'm sure it's not true
he's like the old man in The Simpsons
screaming at the cloud I don't think he
knows what's going on swings are part of
Alzheimer's sure I don't want to give
out bad medical information
imagine though say take that story at
face value imagine how he would be
screaming at Hunter Biden thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time